j'en veux dire une très bonne nouvelle
pour moi est une très bonne nouvelle
pour la france je pense aussi pour la
france alors attendez parce que là les
gens sont contents ils pensent que vous
allez vous baril
[Applaudissements]
ça brasse mentir c'est pas ça ça aurait
peu de ça mais c'est pas ça je vais
rester ami avec vous ça ne changera rien
du tout on restera tous potes parce que
vous êtes des chroniques que j'ai aimé
et j'ai été aussi chroniqueur donc je
sais ce que c'est mais
je passe animateurs
equidia temps d'un tonneau mais s'il
vous plaît pas et qui dia avec hédiard
checchinato la queue de cheval mais n'a
pas le poids des
panneaux mais je te laisse finir
peut-être montré juste pour voir ce que
ça faisait longtemps pendant deux ans je
suis là oh la vache
à lait mais voilà si c'est moi là bas ma
culture
tu vas voir il vaut mieux un petit chez
soi qu'un grand chez les a et la croyais
c'est une connerie n'est pas du tout à
la base il a su de vie je l'espère
[Applaudissements]
il est 18h 54 nous sommes lundi
et je tiens à dire aux autres
chroniqueurs perd personne est au
courant non personne ne
s'est passé des choses ce week-end
[Musique]
[Rires]
je ne comprends pas l'allemand là vous
avez dit quoi
c'est un fait plaisir
l'échec
sur eux
[Musique]
il va y avoir du changement sur ces 8
oui
je peux vous le dire
matthieu delormeau
is back
et chaud pour ceux qui ne comprennent
pas l'anglais ça veut pas dire qu'il a
eu le bac
c'est à dire que matthieu delormeau et
d'euros je vais demander cependant
jamais demandé de ne pas faire de
commentaires pour l'instant
matthieu delormeau
a fait un début de saison exceptionnel
il a illuminé de son talent
touche pas à mon poste le cox
tous les jours n'a pas hésité à donner
son avis n'a pas hésité à mouiller la
chemise
j'espère être là présent le temps
tout le temps fier d'être là
le menton fier
et le zizi points mais
ça non j'ai pas de quoi j'me à berne
c'était pas moi je parlais bien
par la bourse
avec la chaîne ouais enfin café tout le
président
vincent plus jeune
alexandre israël de natanya
vincent bolloré takan hagen tinta gueule
gérald brice viret
je vais sur le dos des militants
et kalou
c'est tellement énorme succès d'antan à
écouter je vous dire qu'on va tout
reprendre depuis le début je sais je
sais pas benjamin castaldi 6 à 7
bernard montiel halle 6 à 6
il est bon jour et et vinyle mondial si
c'est ce
qu'il aime beaucoup bernard arnault sas
est également balayé les ménages il a
maintenant des prime le jeudi soir
mais on avait envie de récompenser
une autre personne
je m'endors on avait deux solutions
sitôt lui faire produire des émissions
et on s'est dit non on ne veut pas
mettre la chaîne en danger
ou bien on va lui donner si on va nous
confier l'animation d'une nouvelle
émission all
et quelle est la spécialité de matthieu
delormeau et chiens à par l'égoïsme
[Rires]
quelle est la spécialité de matthieu
delormeau les tomes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas je suis désolé jaune et
ce n'est peut-être concept la ville
alors même que produire à toi même sa
spécialité les waf waf les chiens tout
ça en raymond
j'ai même pas si la spécialité et
l'animateur c'est un amateur pas de quoi
je vais les mettre aux prises le matin
il peut animer n'importe quoi même à
carrefour poteau combo épaules
et jeudi avec les animateurs des idiots
pour moi c'est beaucoup plus dur que
l'ennemi était l'exacte pour moi les
vrais animateurs c'est vraiment parce
que c'est plus facile c'est plus
difficile que des petits bouts mais tout
terrain mais quand même people moi je
dirais en pole et les réalités médecine
ou l ego si près possible des stars
mekouar et célébrités chalon on part de
ce qu'on parle de ce qu'on est victime
bas les célébrités les jours je vais
vous dire matthieu delormeau gens riches
et devant les gens à problèmes
insolubles à
il connaît toutes les célébrités se
moque une célébrité de nous connaît
mathieu devant moi pour ceux qui
connaissent sa carrière
animé avec brio de nouveau dit oui
je suis plus le plein tellement vrai
tellement vrai
rien fait d'autre pas d'autres
obama sur wikipédia
et pmp people facile
la société de match énorme on les fait
une pub pour les trésors de kellogg's
souvent c'est vrai c'est vrai aussi mal
matthieu delormeau
par revenir à l'antenne mais en tant
qu'animateur
sachez
vous parlera après vous tradis coupe
matthieu delormeau
a animé
à partir de très bientôt
quand il très bientôt c'est très bientôt
c'est quoi c'est quoi une nouvelle
émission
qui s'appellera
j'irai au bout de ma pub
ça donne envie
à
[Applaudissements]
bas ce sera programme court
il va animer une nouvelle émission
qui est en fait une ancienne émission
qui avait un énorme succès alors c'est
vrai et je parlais avec la chaîne ce
week-end
on s'est dit pourquoi pas relancer cette
émission qui a fait les belles heures de
ses huit
noms faisait un million
bof bof au
sepa sepa soient ses passions c'est
émouvant c'est pas maintenant
tpm pipoles aulas va revenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je laisse raconter comment ça s'est
passé raconter la vérité il a su il ya
quelques instants ah c'est pour ça qu'il
est tout frétillant raconter tout tout à
l'heure je suis arrivé chez rim avait
mis un
texto que je peux vous dire balesi tu
viens me voir connard
j'ai succès pour moi
non c'était pour qu'il fasse bien que
c'est à lui que
je suis arrivé dans le couloir il y
avait cinq gardes du corps et deux
assistants devant une porte fermée
j'aime avoir serré lille ont fait
leurs mots laissent leur entrée je suis
entré mettez sur un siège avec deux
barbier autour s'occuper lui les mains
comme ça rentre mais trois ma droite que
je te vois là dans l'axé cela dans laxe
une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle tu
vas laquelle dubois l'a mauvaise tu
ferais pas de production pour nous on a
publé
mais j'ai une très bonne claque ce mets
toi dans l'axé là sa bonne
relance tpm people tu es content ou pas
hélas juste sauté au cou comme ça tout
s'est en
fait pas du tout
un
micro
elle combine plaisir sané petkovic et
tester tous les jours
voilà baden alors j'aime aller dû faire
un bisou non parce que j'étais avec le
voilà c'est très mignon les saignements
comme il est pudique car il aime ou
n'aime pas dire qui peut être gentil qui
un petit coquin tu en as coupé bon hein
est ce que tu es heureux très heureux
très très très heureux et franchement on
est entre amis autour de la table sans
vie qui travaille avec toi mais au cas
où sont autant d'atteintes non
maîtresses
[Applaudissements]